[Music]
[Applause]
you know these owners spend well the
taxpayers spend billions of dollars
building these stadiums and then you
wonder how much are they spending on the
actual field and there are certain
stadiums that have a bad reputation and
met life for the Jetson Giants play has
a bad reputation uh you just had one of
the giant Sterling Shepard who was out
for the year obj tweeted out about that
field as well Albert Breer has been
covering this story Albert uh
how who is the one who signs off on the
quality of a football field when when
stadiums are built or even a week by
week basis of are these playable are
these safe
well the NFL teams
um you know really like are charged with
maintaining that obviously during the
year and then the league office has
people that approve the fields
um you know Dan I think there's a bigger
systemic problem here for the NFL which
is the stadiums have gotten so expensive
that NFL owners feel like they can't
justify having those stadiums for just
10 Dates a year and so what does that
mean that means we got to put a million
events in there we got to put rodeos and
tractor pulls and you know swim meets
and all of this different stuff in those
stadiums and what you find is when you
put a ton of different events in these
stadiums it becomes harder to maintain a
grass field so what do they do they put
down field Turf it's happened even in
places like Carolina like where you look
like Charlotte North Carolina should be
ideal for growing grass right but they
have a turf field why well because they
put a soccer team in there they want to
have more events in there they want to
try to monetize the stadium so a lot of
this comes down to money and it comes
down to money on the other end too which
is are you familiar with the Packers
surface
well I was there when farv played where
it was basically painted a dirt okay
well what they have now is like this
it's like this synthetic it's like a
blend right like it's it's synthetic
natural glass blend it's very expensive
it's very hard to maintain it's I mean
it takes a lot of resources right
all the European soccer clubs use it
um which tells you like that something's
working over there and then if you look
at the package can you think of like a
lot of injuries that have happened at
Lambeau despite the fact that they're in
northern Wisconsin which would be a a
really tough environment to do this
right yeah yeah see so there there is a
solution there and I think more and more
players are asking why aren't more teams
doing what the Packers are doing and why
would the Packers be able to do this and
other teams wouldn't well there's no
owner there to say no right like so you
sort of add all this up and you know I
had a really interesting conversation
with Nick Bosa about this
um you know over the summer and he
obviously tore his ACL on that turf at
MetLife and you know he said to me like
flat out he says it's BS that that
they're making us all play on field Turf
you know he's like we should be playing
on natural grass the same way soccer
players in Europe are he brought up
European soccer players so
um look the NFL PA's president JC
treters brought this up
um you know Nick Bosa again brought it
up to me I know he's very cognizant of
the services he plays on do you look at
the way the Rams have done business
despite the fact they play on field Turf
um in their Stadium like Sean McVay and
that staff they won't let their their
players practice on on fields that they
don't feel like are very high level for
practices this has happened this has
been an issue for them with joint
practices over the years so there are a
lot of people that are very cognizant of
it and I think there are a lot of
players out there that do feel like this
is the owners trying to cut corners and
make more money okay so what's the
solution here can you could Bosa Sue
MetLife Stadium like can can Sterling
Shepard Sue because of the actual
playing surface my guess is no because I
don't think the NFL would leave that and
I don't know for a fact but I mean I I
would think that that is tied up in
collective bargaining which is you know
part of why the NFL PA has a hand in
approving the fields
um and you know I I just I I don't think
Dan that it's necessarily that there's
not the right process in place for
approving the fields I think what most
players are saying now a lot of players
are saying now is that the bar isn't
high enough you know like the process is
in place to approve the fields but is
the standard for our fields too low and
I think it's very easy again for a lot
of these players to look overseas and
say how come you see these soccer teams
over in Europe doing all this to protect
their players and our teams and our
owners aren't and I think it's a very
fair question to ask now like in some
circumstances indoor stadiums I like I
understand like why like you feel like
maybe you have to have field Turf but
even in those cases like look at Arizona
and Vegas right like Arizona and Vegas
have those trays that pull the field
outside so you can have you can grow
grass outside well why wouldn't an owner
want to do that do you know what that
costs an owner costs an owner parking
right like so Arizona and Vegas like I
mean it's great that they're doing it
but one one thing I think for a lot of
owners well one thing with a lot for a
lot of owners I think would look at that
and say well that's going to cost me x
amount of parking spots which is x
amount out of Revenue over the course of
a year and when you add it up and you're
trying to put all these events in a
stadium whether it's you know NFL games
soccer games concerts whatever it is
like you're going to cost yourself x
amount of money a lot of owners just
aren't willing to do that we're talking
Albert Breer senior NFL reporter lead
content strategist at the Monday Morning
Quarterback what did you see on the Tua
play and then the subsequent events
sure it looked really bad I mean like
look like you know Matt Milano
um you know obviously was flagged for
the the hit to his head bounces off the
turf
um I mean like he almost looked like a
woozie drunk like getting up like and
that's like sort of like I think what we
all associate with head injuries right
like in the way that he kind of stumbled
to the ground and it looked really
really bad and I was very skeptical in
the moment obviously the Dolphins pushed
out the back injury narrative very
quickly like in game they push that
narrative out there after they'd
previously announced that he was being
evaluated for a head injury at this
point though Dan like I it's just
it's something very Sinister would have
to be at work for this still to be for
for them still to be covering something
up because like you'd have to have
people the league office people on the
dolphin staff people
um the independent um you know
concussion spotter
um Tua himself like there would have to
be so many people complicit at this
point in covering this thing up
I just think it's more likely that this
was a like a just a bad coincidence
where tuo really did have a back injury
and um and and and his head happened to
bounce off the turf and that he tweaked
his back that way
um you know again like I I think it's
right to be skeptical and the NFL's made
its bet on this
um over the years it's right to be
skeptical on all sorts of concussion
issues when it comes to the NFL and it's
great that the NFL PA is looking into
this it's just hard for me to imagine
that there would be that many people at
this point that would sign off on
keeping Tua out of the concussion
protocol with a Thursday night game
coming
um like a lot of people would be putting
themselves at risk in doing that to try
to cover this but but this this is
another thing it's like he didn't have a
concussion but he had something to do
with his back that made him react that
way Albert right that sounds like it
might be a little more serious but
nobody's like what is the back injury
here it it's he didn't have a concussion
okay but is there something else here
that where hey don't don't look over
here we're just going to let you know
that he didn't have a concussion right
and I mean that's definitely a question
and look like that's just sort of I
think it's the way these things have
gone right like over the last 15 years
is that you know we've all been sort of
trained and they've made great progress
when it comes to head injuries I mean
they were coming from a really low point
no question but but they've made
progress when it comes to head injuries
and I think we've all been sort of
trained in our head to think football
players can play through everything else
butt head injuries now it used to be
football players play through everything
right and now it's like football players
play through everything but head
injuries and I mean look like we sort of
glorify that to some degree right like
we glorify when a guy goes out there and
he's able to kind of fight through
something I think we've stopped
glorifying it with head injuries but we
glorify it with everything else and so
um yeah I mean I I think you know it's
probably part of just our the culture of
the way we like follow the sport we
cover the sport now where it's like
don't make a guy a hero for playing
through a head injury but make him a
hero for playing through everything else
and accept that just that's the nature
of the sport that you have to play
through everything else I meant
mentioned this early you got uh
Baltimore facing Buffalo Big Show down
here and I keep hearing this week in and
week out Lamar Jackson bet on himself
and just like Aaron judged it but I
don't know like what is the end game for
Lamar Jackson what is he hoping to get
that he didn't get how much it feels
like there's a finite amount of money
yeah that he can get is it is it the
guarantee or is it a mahomesian type of
deal
well let me let me just position this an
interesting way to you where maybe it's
not totally about the money for Lamar
um he has played he has run the ball at
a historic rate over the first four
years of his career right and they
deploy him in a way that no quarterback
even Cam Newton
um has been deployed I I mean in modern
NFL history
um no one's ever done this with a
quarterback before and last year for the
first time that actually took him off
the field his first three years it
didn't right and as much as like there
might have been mileage put on his body
and everything else didn't take him off
the field last year for the first time
it took him off the field he missed five
games
so I think most of us would look at that
and most players too would look at that
and say God Lamar you should really cash
out you know like just take what you can
get now because something more serious
could happen
what if Lamar looks at it the other way
what if Lamar looks at it because he's
always thought differently we know he's
a different guy that's part of what
makes him great
what if Lamar looks at this and says you
know what
I'm not going to mitigate your Financial
Risk look at the amount of physical risk
I'm taking on
I'm not mitigating your Financial Risk
four five six years from now like if you
guarantee the first three years of my
deal that means that you are giving
yourself out in the three or four years
after that and if this is part of the
bargain that I've got to take on this
amount of physical risk to play this
position and there's no precedent for a
quarterback taking on the physical risk
that I'm taking on
hell no I'm not going to mitigate your
your financial so this is just he does
he want to do Sean Watson 200.
I mean Dan like that my reader I think
there's principle involved here right I
think he wants like I I and look like
what I can tell you is 100 what you're
saying like this is not about that like
one thing I know is this is not about
raw dollars like last year they were
willing to go to the Josh Allen number
this year they've been willing to go up
over 45 million per which is where the
market is right now this is not about
the raw money this is about doing
guarantees and structures guarantees and
structure in a different way than we've
traditionally seen quarterbacks done
which is what DeSean Watson got right
and what's what what Kirk Cousins got
um five years ago or four years ago in
Minnesota and
well Mars asking the Ravens to I think
Wilmar is asking the Ravens to do that
without there being multiple bidders
which is the difference in the cousin
situation in the Watson situation from
every other one right cousins and Watson
had multiple bitters which I think is
why it got to the point that it got to
in those cases
um so like but I don't think that this
is just about like Lamar collecting
every every dollar if it was to me if
this was really about money
the Ravens would have been able to find
the number that Lamar couldn't say no to
because that's what this is really about
right at some point the number would
have gotten to a point where Lamar would
have said you know what 150 million
dollars that's good enough I'll do it to
me like and just knowing a little bit
about Lamar knowing about NFL precedent
I just it feels to me like this is about
principle and if you really think about
any sort of reverse engineer it that way
Dan where you say to yourself if you're
Lamar might you be a little ticked off
if you're taking on all this physical
risk and they're asking to mitigate your
Financial Risk you can see where maybe
he would think that way yeah I wondered
about if you guarantee it
um but so you think the Ravens are
saying you know we sort of want to
guarantee this we don't want to complete
okay and well so so here's the thing is
like and and really the reason why
things aren't this way so I remember
talking to you know a few teams after
the Kirk Cousins did his deal and I
remember asking like is this gonna be
the trendsetter is this like the the
tide Turner you know so to speak and
they all said it's an agents too they
all said like it just depends on what
the next contracts look like and then
Matt Ryan did a conventional quarterback
deal and Aaron Rodgers did a
conventional quarterback deal we were
back to square one right and same thing
happened this year where you know
DeShaun Watson does his deal in March
and everybody's like oh cool could this
be the trendsetter and well Kyler Murray
Derek Carr uh they do conventional
quarterback deals after
um after after DeSean Watson's deal gets
done and it seems like we're back to
square one so like
I the what the Ravens were asking Lamar
to do as a conventional quarterback deal
which is where things had sort of reset
after the DeSean Watson deal and it
feels to me at least like he's the first
person to stand on principle in this and
what's really interesting about Dan I
had a discussion with a really smart
executive couple years ago who was in a
quarterback negotiation about this and
he said to me he said my job isn't to
pay him what he thinks he's worth my job
isn't to pay him what the market says
he's worth my job is to find the number
he can't say no to and that's
effectively what the Raiders were able
to do with Carr That's effectively what
the Cardinals were able to do with Kyler
Murray and obviously that's something
the Ravens haven't been able to do with
Lamar I'll get to this quickly and let
you go thank you again for your time the
giant situation with Daniel Jones and
saquon Barkley
I think they've already kind of sent the
message to Daniel Jones hey we're not
picking up your option saquan do you
want to get into the let's extend a
running back to a second contract here
I mean this is a faceless Team without
those two but I wonder as they move past
this season
our saquon Barkley and Daniel Jones on
the Giants
I'll say no on Daniel Jones
um I'll say maybe on saquon Barkley I
think what Barclay it sort of depends on
what the market dictates and my guess
would be that the Giants would let him
go to the market and say we'll work with
you on a contract but like we're not
going to break the bank at this point
because he is a running back five years
in and he does have injury history now
and I think it's it's really instructive
because I do think that they followed
the pattern um through their first nine
months there
like it's instructive to look at like
where Joe Shane and and Brian Dave all
came from and that's Buffalo and if you
look at the way that the bills built
what they've built there and I think
everybody's impressed with what they've
built there they did have sort of faces
of the franchise when they got there
right and Tyrod Taylor was there and
Kyle Williams on defense was there and
they slowly transitioned out from
underneath those guys and if you look at
that team now look at the core of the
team every single one of them is a Sean
McDermott Brandon Bean guy every single
one of them right so so much of what
Buffalo did they had good players
in-house they made the playoffs that
first year was about how do we
transition out of the old era and into
the new era and so I guess it'd be going
to be a big part of what the Giants do
in the same way McDermott and bean had
confidence in themselves that they'd be
able to bring in the right guys over
time which they did and guys like Josh
Allen and Tre Davis White and Tremaine
Edmonds and Stefan Diggs and all of
those guys Micah hi Jordan poyer
um I think the that Shane and Dave all
have the same sort of confidence that
they're going to find a way to bring in
the right kind of guys to be the faces
of their franchise a couple years from
now final 30 seconds is there a coach
right now already in trouble
I mean the conversation is going to
continue on that rule and and Mike
McCarthy
um I think over the course of the year
McCarthy's I think done himself a favor
and winning with Cooper Rush
um the last couple of weeks so you know
I I don't know that discussion is quite
as hot as it was
um a couple weeks ago on Mike McCarthy a
rule is just going to have to deal with
it over the course of this year
um so that's one and then I think
another one to watch is is Lovey Smith
in Houston there is such a critical
point for their franchise and and I it's
hard to predict a franchise will go one
and done two years in a row but you've
got names like Josh McCown and Jonathan
Gannon that sort of have connections in
the organization and I I think I'll be
sort of hovering over that thing what
about Cliff Kingsbury
he just signed through 2027.
I'm shocked that they did it I mean that
was the thing is that that was the
bigger surprise was that they did those
contracts and you know I think we all
came out of that blowout loss the Rams
thinking okay
Cliff's unnoticed Steve keim's unnoticed
even Kyler might be unnoticed all those
guys have New Deals now and you know I
think a big part of it becomes it's not
just is the owner willing to eat all
that money if he fires guys or gets rid
of guys who have these contracts it's
also admitting you are wrong you know
what I mean like and it was such a big
swing on cliff in the first place in
2019 and they made the playoffs last
year and they've made progress over
three years
like you you you make that decision you
make the progress you double down
if you're Michael Bidwell are you
willing to admit that you were wrong I
think that's a big part of it and I
think that could be a factor in the rule
thing too I mean honestly like David
Tepper took a awfully big swing and
giving Matt rule a seven year contract
um you know in 2020 when does he get to
the point where he's willing to admit
he's wrong I think that's a factor in
these sorts of situations where coaches
have so much term left on their
contracts thanks again Albert you got
Dan that's Albert Breer he is the Monday
Morning Quarterback
mmqb.com we'll take a break phone calls
coming up close-up shop after this